[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about owning
your own genomic data we have Dennis
Christian joining us on the show hello
it's my pleasure to be here
hello thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me we are very
excited to be featuring you we're also
very grateful that we ended up finding
each other after we did the interview of
George church at the lab and then you
were like hey I love Ian the bear yeah
we wanted yeah we won't talk about
nebula genomics and I'm very excited to
be talking about this with you it's a
pivotal time in the field of of genomic
data and and the way that we can do so
many of the things the right way the
first time going through it so for those
that don't know Dennis's background he
spent two years last years is the
co-founder in chief science officer at
nebula genomics he loses a privacy
focused personal genomics company also
he's a PhD candidate at Harvard Medical
School doing genomic data privacy and a
lot of interesting steps have happened
to get there in in your in your journey
which we're gonna get to Dennis teach us
about your thoughts on the current state
of humanity interesting question
so I think we are living in an
interesting time maybe a start with kind
of a historical perspective on that and
you know tell you where we are in terms
of technological advancement so if you
think how far we have come and sink back
and you know 18th century no sing about
steam machine that's when I think human
civilization we started take off
technologically then throughout the 19th
century we had you know further
developments of of tools that have you
know facilitated us to do more work more
easily than chemistry had its big time
in the 19th century we figured out how
in all synthesized
all types of different compounds and use
them for different cases whether it's
you know just colors or medicine then in
the early first half of the 20th century
physics had its big big time is you know
relativity theory quantum mechanics
unfortunately culminating in the atomic
bombs then second half of the 20th
century we had you know the digital age
starting with the invention of the
transistor and then culminating in the
Internet and I think today many people
believe we are entering the age of
biotech know biology of essentially
using what we learned in the previous
centuries in technologies we have
developed to better understand biology
specifically human biology and actually
applying that to make you know as with
all other types of technology just our
lives better
longer and you know more comfortable and
part of this you know biological biotech
revolution is I think genomics
revolution that has been driven by the
decreasing costs of human genome
sequencing and this is essentially what
has enabled companies like near people
genomics to be yes yes I love your big
history perspective really gives the
last multi multiple hundred years into a
into a very you know you're following
the technological impacts that have that
have taken place on society and then you
bring us all the way up to to this
biotech explosion that's that is being
talked about as a 100 trillion dollar
explosion in the 21st century and I'm
like wow that's crazy that that all
these potentials exist and you know in
all aspects of health care agriculture
all its everywhere the way that that it
that the impact is coming in and so now
you you know you also mentioned
especially in biology it's this Carlson
curve kind of like Moore's Law the
sequencing has dropped in price so much
and I think that that is a that's a very
very important reason why companies like
nebula can actually exist and have the
mission that they that they do today
which I know you will get to an unpack
now Dennis when you know when you find
yourself
you know being born in Azerbaijan and
going to Germany and then coming to you
actually went to Japan to damn work
there because in Japan in Japan and then
to the east coast to Harvard you know
tell us about you know you as a kid and
and picking up your interests yeah so I
think when I grew up I always wanted to
be a scientist so my father is a chemist
who has been you know teaching at the
University when I was growing up in Baku
my my mother got his education of an
engineer and worked briefly in that
profession so I think I'm kind of very
early decided that I want to kind of do
science and then a little bit later in
my life I also realized that I wanted to
something translational so not only you
know do science in the lab and publish
papers but I actually try to bring out
my work out of the laboratory and have
to have it more impact and yeah so I I
grew up in Baku as you said and then my
family moved to Germany where we went to
middle school high school and received
my undergrad degree from the University
of Freiburg and you knew then that you
wanted to do the bite in biology
around that time refiguring that oh yeah
well the university system in germany is
a bit different than in the US they you
have actually to decide exactly one what
you want to be even before you apply so
yeah so it's you know much more focused
justing has advantages and disadvantages
but when I was applying for for college
I was applying to a specific biology
program bio so I wanted to be you know
scientists in the field of biomedicine
generally speaking and during the course
of my undergrad studies I think I wanted
more than just to be a typical
biologists I increasingly got interested
in technology and how we can use that
technology to essentially better study
biology and then also apply what we
learned I I got a second degree a second
undergrad we which in what is
essentially Electrical Engineering
and after that wanted to get some
experience abroad when we went to Japan
as you mentioned before for for a few
months
worked there on some a micro fluidics
technology for sensitive to enable
sequencing of single cells spent a few
months working on that and micro
fluidics to enable sequencing of a
single cell yeah that's that's a yeah
also a with emerging emerging field so
far you know when people have been
talking about the sequencing they were
they had what they had in mind is just
sequencing more bulk samples so you know
you just take like an odd bunch of cells
like from saliva or from blood or some
kind of tissue and then just sequence
all of them assuming they're all the
same but as we have found out in the
last few years that's not the case there
are differences between the cells on
different levels whether it's you know
the genome the epigenome or the
transcriptome so more and more research
is happening on kind of really figuring
out how individual cells work on those
different levels and here I was working
well did some very early initial work on
a device to you know isolate single
cells to be able to sequence them so
that's what I worked on in Japan and and
after that I came to Boston to the
laboratory you know professor george
church where i am right now i ph d--
student so back then I just came for a
brief internship and I walked back then
on you know CRISPR that was just know
just invented literally year before so
it was an exciting time and a place to
be and during that time in addition to
doing just to research in the lab I also
got involved I guess just as a student
intern this is another one of his
George's startup companies and really
like this experience of you know doing
research in the lab and then translating
into a company into a product and I
liked that and also generally doing
research in during this lab so I decided
I want to stay here and they were to get
you know my my PhD degree
in this laboratory and then possibly
even start a company with I believe is
George at some point later so I applied
to Harvard to MIT for PhD programs so is
the goal of coming back to George's lab
to do my PhD thesis work so this
unfortunately unfortunately worked out
and then in 2015 I started my my PhD
studies in George's laboratory initially
working on some sequencing technology to
essentially be able to resolve some
regions of the human genome that remain
unseen ones to date so we kind of tend
to say oh we have sequence the human
genome right but it's not entirely true
we actually sequenced only like 95
percent of it and they still fact the
sense that remain missing that he
actually unable to sequence reserve with
a currently available technology due to
some limitations which I don't want to
go into but I was working on a way to
overcome this and while working on this
what I think I realized is that why it's
kind of important to get the missing 5%
what a small port to actually bring all
the technologies already have that we
can use to give the 95 percent to be
just used much more broadly so to bring
it out of the laboratory out of academic
research and have more people sequence
their genomes and you know shares a data
which and you know accomplishes that has
been in George's I think life call
admission for four decades he he know he
helped develop this technology that
brought the costs down of sequencing
from hundreds of millions of dollars to
to less than one thousand dollars today
but so far it's you know we mostly used
in academia very few people actually did
any kind of genetic testing especially
not whole genome sequencing and you know
usually access question when I give
talks of you know did any kind of
genetic testing coding of submitting mmm
usually nobody raises the head so that
that's that's a problem that George has
been trying to solve for very long time
so I decided essentially to start a
company with a goal of addressing that
problem and we asked ourselves what our
you know the issues that essentially
deter people from getting sick
and what we came to understand is that
for example privacy concerns have become
an increasing increasing issue
especially in the past few years and
it's crazy that that took the number one
seat over money that privacy took the
number onc yeah so you know money is a
sizing second close second and that's
you know also one of the things that we
trying to address brings the cost close
to two to zero and we are already on the
right trajectory because the costs are
coming down but the privacy concern is
actually on the opposite trajectories
and growing the more data we generate
the more you know the more entities are
who are interested in that data and the
more concerns are coming up so we
realized this is an unmet need and says
there's a problem to be solved and and
we also have actually the technology to
do that so we decided to kind of bring
together the field of you know DTC
director consumer genetics and
cryptography to create a privacy for
personal genomics company you have the
fact that cost is decreasing but privacy
is increasing at Skype and they could
think that complication is is ironic but
there's a lot of you know spiritual
awakening that humanity can do to make
it easier for for people to not be asked
at fear for there to be less malevolence
for there to be more benevolence and and
and kindness and therefore them the
privacy decree that concerns decrease as
well and ok so now as you start personal
genomics company with nebula genomics
now and we have we have we have slides
to to bring up along the way as well you
know the big why this is a this is a
huge deal like you were indicating for
you and George you because you're just
wanting to see this cost go from a
hundred million dollar sequence down to
zero and that's because we gain so much
valuable insight so tell us more about
this big
why and eradicating disease with this
collective intelligence that we get to
have all these points are so interesting
not a big why yeah so your DNA
essentially your blueprint right it
makes you unique if you had an identical
twin you will be identical to you
because of your DNA because that's what
you share and as seen on this slide your
your DNA defines a lot about you totally
completely defines your looks your your
physical appearance it becomes
increasingly clear that also your
personality tastes things like that are
strongly influenced by biogenetics then
your health things like you know disease
risks for example predispositions to
certain types of cancers or diseases you
know like Alzheimer's they have also
very strong genetic component and you
know ancestry obviously also something
that has been you know driving people to
purchase different types of genetic
tests and I think what's important to
keep in mind when thinking about all
those different points is that we still
don't understand most of the human
genome it's 6 billion bases and we do
not know what most of them do and to get
to that point and to get to that point
that we actually do understand more of
it we need generate more data and share
that data with researchers who for
example can use that data to find new
correlations between certain traits
easily can be disease Buddhist positions
for example and and genetics so there's
an ongoing processes there studies
published essentially every day that
that shine more and more light on so far
unknown parts of the human genome so for
one individual gets sequenced it's not
just you know I want I'm saying you get
sequence you get some kind of report and
then you done with it right that's not
how it is it's really a kind of you set
on a journey you start a journey you get
you get you you get your data you get
your genome you get your initial results
but more results are coming out every
day like the blueprint and just put it
on the shelf exactly with it you contact
me give more if you start to start you
know essentially I guess the process of
lifelong learning about yourself
and that that would genomic essentially
enables its to even I mean today kind of
you can already get a lot of insight
from it but what you need to have this
longtime perspective what you will learn
over time how much you're gonna need and
and you know the pace of research is
accelerating we discussed the earlier
kind of age age of biotech genomics so
more and more
so essentially the genome will become
more and more useful to you as a time
progresses yeah yeah this oh oh this
this added dimension of time is so
important to to put into the healthcare
equation because if you're constantly
observing your body all your biometrics
over time you're able to predict
pathologies developing and you're able
to tackle them you're retain youthful
homeostatic capacity all these cool
things that can enable you to be
healthier longer more creative
experience more things these are these
are very major pillars of the anti-aging
communities
drive and desire as well and I love how
you call it a blueprint you know it's
like understanding yourself and and this
is a very beautiful part of it you know
no for the last six million years of
evolution there's never a time that you
could take the DNA and sequence it and
yeah yeah yeah I mean I gave us examples
you know chemistry physics and so on and
so far it has been kind of more about
understanding nature and now we at the
point we're actually understanding
ourselves and because of that I think
the current you know age of biotech can
to us to us as you know humans humanity
can be known will be more impactful than
potentially is and everything that came
before it
yeah yeah I love it
okay let's um on the next slide that we
have this was kind of another one of
these big huge like moments for me when
this the curve in terms of people that
are partaking in getting their genetic
sequence is just it's going up so fast
yeah and then the issue comes up like
you've indicated earlier that people are
whole breaks what's happening with this
data yeah
are are you am i owning it do you own it
are you selling it is the government
involved and so then there does the
breaks happened and now it's like let's
think about this yeah yeah so yeah as
you said you know the adoption is
growing more more people are aware also
opportunity to get genetic tests so this
curve actually not shows real sequencing
beta but actually just genotyping data
which is you know Stewart genetic tests
but a much lower resolution but still
the availability of genetic tests people
are increasingly aware of it and users
opportunity to learn of those very
things techno health and ancestry and
you know various various traits and it's
great that you know it has been an
exponentially growing space the more
data generated the better you know
sharing data is also good but questions
as you said you know are now coming up
is there enough transparency who is
really making the decisions whether data
shared or not and for one they're just
those concerns that have been created
the deter many people from from getting
any kind of genetic tests and in
addition to those concerns
let's open questions and others risks
real can for example someone be denied
insurance based on genetics or can
anything else bad happened if you know
we do not you know emphasize more and
how important for privacy of genetic
base and give people an opportunity to
protect it yeah and in that next slide
is all of the crazy headlines as well of
yeah this just illustrates that how much
attention the space is getting
I mean so if you you know if you look at
what what you know the age of Internet
has brought us uses DNA to track people
yeah this type of stuff is not so where
are our devices are already give us the
location data all the time there yeah
yeah yeah so what people listen come to
understand today is that there are many
organizations they just like to track
some of you know to monetize their data
was it you know Google Facebook and
others often it's you know about
targeted advertising and things like
that and then if they think about what
you know what's the most personal data
that they own it's probably on my search
history but it's my DNA and there are
companies that might be interested
monetizing that then they get very very
nervous about this and headlines like
that just countless headlines like that
all over the internet many articles
being written literally every day about
about some toes no genomics companies
are being hacked or just confusing the
data in a way that that people find
concerning yeah yeah this is this is
nuts
you know and and and as you said you
know in addition to just as companies
they're also government's dealing in
years increasingly so the year 2018 was
a year when I think in the u.s. in
particular the law enforcement
discovered how useful genomic databases
are just as crazy yes teachers which is
well the basic idea is that you know
there many unsolved crimes that might
have been committed decades ago so you
have a Christ crime scene and you know a
sample that you found on that crime is a
biological sample from which you can
extract a DNA that potentially belongs
to the suspect but how do we find that
suspect was just a DNA enhance you need
some kind of a database to match it
against and today we are at a point
where we have tens of millions of people
who got a genetic test so as you know
law enforcement like you know police or
FBI what you can do you can take that
sample go to that database try to match
it against that database to either find
that individual in that database because
their individual go
test at some point but that's not even
necessary because it's already enough
it's just a distant relative of that
individual quarter data fat what that
test didn't get a partial match you can
connect with that relative and then
through the Miss collaboration or that
relative try to trace back the actual
criminal
so the first famous case was you know
the Golden State Killa in California
that that attracted a lot of attention
but since then they really create dozens
of additional cases which is you know
generally a good thing right when those
decade old cables are being solved and
you know those models apprehended yes
but the problem is that the way that
it's done is it's at costs of people's
privacy so the law enforcement just
issued subpoenas to a personal genomics
companies access as a data basis without
really asking people for permission with
this data can be used I think most
people would kind of agree that you know
they won't want would want to help
apprehend the suspects but this practice
to be no lack strength transparency and
lacks that's you know
it lacks respect of people's privacy
which which raid is concerned and then
of course other countries like China
where and you know some other countries
that are more authoritarian where
genomic databases are using them in much
more concerning ways than they are today
in the US just when it when you're
saying that that story the third cousin
can if they got sequence that how many
how many more people does that basically
bring into the genetic pool that didn't
even didn't even say that they wanted to
be sequence yeah so there wasn't really
for recent study in science that showed
that there's a county existing databases
that about you know 20 million people
also already sixty percent of the US
population can essentially be identified
indirectly by you know having just your
cousin in the database so we are I guess
or gets at the point where it's kind of
too late yeah so that we that 23 million
is just us know that's that world it's
it's
it's globally but the u.s. in terms of
direct consumer genetics has been you
know leading dominating me are like 5
million of those have been in the u.s.
well I think like me over 90 percent of
them have been in the u.s. 90 percent
yes
okay so then with 20 million let's say
sequences you can have let's say almost
a hundred if 70 million people be
identified yeah say yeah I mean I think
over half of the US population or 150
million people can be traced back and
that's what the study says that's crazy
and they didn't even opt into the system
yeah that's a interesting thing about
DNA right for example you share your DNA
with your mother with your father with
your siblings so if you decide to take a
test you're actually sharing their DNA
and they add say equity an interesting
kind of privacy consent aspect to
anything involving involve genetics
because your your DNA is not yours alone
you share it with a lot of people
interesting yes the consent question but
you would have thought that you'd have
to go ask your family if you could get
your dream sequence yeah I mean you
today you don't have to test you know no
regulations that tell you you need to
ask them before you get a genetic pair
so it's a great areas that so far has
been not regulated in any way yeah Wow
okay and then now now okay in the next
in the next couple what is what is that
what is that Ronnie you have like a
whole big yeah my brother did legacy
tree genealogists and he's real into you
know where we're from and Jonna did yeah
interesting I've yet to read this I
don't care
there's gonna be stuff in here that I
don't like I'm probably from some crazy
people what was it called genealogy
legacy like I don't know this one
interesting but there's there know many
many personal genomics across like
yeah yeah well William we're gonna break
down the differences to run let's go to
the next slides too cuz I wanna I want
to be explaining this with the visuals
as we go you kind of broke this down
already we're understanding the disease
you can teach us definitely teach us
more
well actually this would probably be a
good time to explain the difference
between what ancestry and 23andme do
which is oh you were teaching me earlier
there's if there's six billion bases and
that you have to get those individual
data points that that that if you only
get 500,000 of those of those most you
can call it like a Pareto principle like
you're looking for the slots that have
the highest chance of having a mutation
that makes in disease happen
yeah and so there's a difference between
doing it that way which is what 23
million and ancestry do versus your way
which is a whole genome it's a low pass
whole genome sequence yeah and then how
does that affect them the diseases the
drugs trials right so you know the
genetic data that is being generated
tend you know if it's being shared it
can help advance know to basic research
helping just better understand human
genetics you know our blueprints and
that knowledge can use be used for
example for drug discovery finding for
example new correlations between a
certain gene and a certain medical
condition then you could after that
develop like small molecule a drug that
will target that protein that's you know
being produced from that gene and that's
kind of early stage of the drug
discovery process and then at the
genomic data can also be used at later
stages you know did for example during
clinical trials where we have a problem
two days that the drug development costs
keep increasing and much more and more
drugs are feeling and that's partially
due to still our approach to pursuing
that one drug fits all which is not
necessarily true because we are
different yeah
so how do we build drugs for that as I
personalized
we know work for those you know specific
groups of people and to do that you need
a century to incorporate genomic
creatine your drug discovery pipelines
and your clinical trials to and if you
do that you can have you know smaller
clinical trials
you could only specific people who have
you know specific genetic genetic
variants in the genome that you believe
rubies will respond to the treatment and
you will have higher success rates
because of that so this is essentially
the path towards personalized medicine
where not just everyone get to prescribe
the same drug but based on your your
genetic background now the questions
that you brought up before how there's a
date that we generating different from
the data that other personal genomics
companies are generating so we uses more
novel technology called next-generation
DNA sequencing which which essentially
can be used to read almost all six
billion paid more than six billion pages
in the human genome what most other
personal genomics companies doing they
are just getting a snapshot they reading
out only about less than 0.1% of your
whole genome it's like you know it's
like you read a book and you read only
one letter every ten pages and then you
try to figure out the rest so you can
imagine that that's difficult and you
miss a lot
why do is actually trying to read the
whole book and we at a point in time
where this is possible at an affordable
cost because single letters are also
very meaningful which is why they yes is
there any meaningful I mean this data
that has been generated is useful but it
has its limitations and with
next-generation DNA sequencing we can
essentially overcome those limitations
for example an academic lab
next-generation DNA sequencing has
already completely replaced
genotype linked its genotyping is just
not not used anymore and the same thing
will happen I think most definitely in
the direct to consumer market as well
because the prices just keep approaching
each other and at some point just won't
make any sense anymore to just you know
beat the less than 0.1% of the genome
that we can do the whole thing almost at
the same cost and we're getting to that
point now Dennis let me ask you this
then if when you're looking at
the entire almost the entire six billion
bases are you passing when you're doing
this this low pass at one time do you
those five hundred thousand or so that
that have a high propensity for having a
variation that causes something bad that
do you can you can you focus more of
your attention on that to make sure you
get the right letter yeah so this next
generation DNA's in which you can
combine both essentially random sampling
of the whole genome at low coverage but
you can also focus more on certain genes
that are all fulfilling kind of more
importance there's for example a set of
59 genes called SMG 59 that are that I
defined that being particularly
important because if you find something
in those genes there's actually
actionable steps you can take for
example to prevent you know getting sick
or do we be able to achieve a therapy so
we can for example do whole genome at
low pass at low coverage from that get
your answers you get a lot of you know
contacts but then focus on your small
subset of genes that are particularly
important to get to get you we know
health-related information that might be
very important to you and but but at the
end of the day is just temporary
I think solution because what you want
to do in the end is to be sequence the
whole genome at high coverage and that's
at products we'll be launching soon so
today what you can buy if you go to the
nebula website is you know the small
pass whole genome sequencing but it will
start offering high coverage whole
genome sequencing soon as well
interesting so you you can actually get
an action item even from the low pass
you can get an action item that you can
maybe through a process of maybe
exercise or nutrition or whatever it may
be that you could slowly become less and
less likely to develop a disease yeah
and that this type of is like this is
big this is a big part of the why for
people is that you can take action with
your blueprint and and and better live
healthier throughout your life then yeah
this gonna be crazy one
high resolution yeah so genomes we are
being a little bit careful you seen over
the Lopez sequencing uh when especially
when people try women give people a day
times I try to extract health
information from it we tell them this is
only 99% accurate so be careful if you
find something you know go to a
physician to confirm it or just wait for
for our high coverage sequencing for
which we'll be able to tell you know
this 99.999 percent accuracy whether you
know you have a certain certain variant
or not yes yes okay and let's go to the
next image Ronnie so this is this is
really interesting when when when you
were teaching about this I was thinking
that there was a a like like this is
almost as though it's it's like
shattering all of the data silos that's
what I love about nebula
I love shattering data silos because in
it across every single field of science
the more that we can work on a
transparent and open level the faster we
can advance the edge of science the more
we can understand about ourselves and
and so okay so you're when I when I
submit you know the link to nebula
genomics is below but when when I when I
submit a payment right now it's only
like 20 bucks yeah right it's only 20
bucks right now and then I get your
saliva kit and then I submit the submit
my saliva to you then you guys do
low-pass sequencing and then you are
working on how to anonymize that most
effectively yeah right now so we are
working on several complementary
approaches to make sure that your
privacy and your data essentially
protected throughout throughout the
whole process so the first feature that
we're working on right now is just
making it anonymous which means that we
want to enable you to get sequenced or
get the test get the results without us
even knowing who you are and and this
means that you should be able to pay for
your sequencing anonymously and you
should be able to receive your
saliva collection kitten anonymously and
submitted to us without us knowing your
name your credit card number your
address any identifiable information
Wow so that's what you pay with
cryptocurrency that's what that's one
option right so we that's a toe step
right you do the babies generated
anonymously the second step is once the
data is generated how do we make sure
that you are in control of your data and
you know you the only one again decide
what happens to it there's several
approaches there that you can take for
example we can just encrypt it give you
the password and you essentially the
only one who has and be able to decrypt
it it has some disadvantages because
they use if you lose password your data
is gone we cannot reset your password if
we improve we unable to that an
alternative is to split your password
essentially in multiple pieces and get
those pieces to multiple independent
organizations which kind of exam one be
nonprofits or groups that support
biomedical research so this way you
distribute trust there's no longer
single parties that you need trust and
your data can be only the group that
made accessible if this you know consent
between those party said we know this
use case is you know Verint it and as a
researcher who requesting accesses can
can be trusted so for that we use this
you know multi-party access control as I
just described and block change actually
communicate emissions communicate
consent so you can for example say I
allow you know John Doe from that pharma
company to use my data yes and that end
to the blockchain and all those multiple
parties who hold the keys can read out a
center from the blockchain see that you
gave the permission then decrypt your
data and give permission to the John Doe
from from the pharma company army
interesting the next see you you have
these are like valves
yeah you get to control the flow of your
of your genomic data for for research
yeah yeah so the second step essentially
enabling controllability and
transparency which you know blockchain
helps us accomplish both and the third
step is that once you decided to share
your data with that researcher how do
you make sure that it's not misused and
there are several approaches there as
well so the most basic one is just in
giving your data to that researcher you
bring the computations to the data
so essentially ask the researcher what
do you want to compute give us your your
algorithms we will run them ourselves on
that data and return you only the
results so that you know the most basic
way to to protect the data privacy and
it can be supplemented by some
additional technologies for example
today most of this computation happen in
clouds right like you know Google cloud
AWS and then the question might come up
how do you make sure you trust Google
and Trust Amazon because they are the
ones storing the data and computing on
the data and to address that issue some
other technologies can be used one of
them well which are generally called the
Sentry privacy-preserving technologies
and at the core of those technologies
the idea of computing unencrypted data
actually having data in encrypted form
never actually decrypting it so you know
the cloud storage provider can actually
never see the data but still a query or
pipeline can be executed on the data
some result can be generated which is
also encrypted and also not visible to
the storage and computing provider and
the encrypted result can be the shared
with the researcher and the research is
able to decrypt the result and you'll
see what he wanted to find out and
through the process essentially no one
has seen the data you have a ton of
possible possibilities to explore here
you may even go with multiple ways of
yeah that's an important point because
all of those things are complementary
it's it's it's they not replace each
other you know this first one and it was
anonymity then blockchain is about
transparency and control and the third
one is about actually protecting privacy
of shared data and you know an ideal
system will be combining all of them
whoa it's so interesting hearing you
talk about all of the different ways
that this can be done I love it I love
it and and it's very exciting to think
about what like kind of what the
iterations are gonna be like with with
this with this anonymity control and
security all these components okay let's
go to the next one now this is again
this is one of the you know that was one
of the highest privacy concern was
privacy for people not doing the getting
involved testing this image is extremely
interesting to me because I am so
excited about learning about what people
are actually doing with the data like
I'm just thinking about these devices
that we use all the time but we'd have
no idea how the data is really being
used the closest you get is like your
GPS you get to know when there's traffic
on the road that's because people are
sharing the data and you've learned that
right but this is so cool because I can
actually learn what research is being
done using my biometrics and then I can
engage with the researchers and it
becomes like a whole learning I love
learning right so this becomes a whole
learning and engagement process with
science yeah yeah yeah that's an
important point I mean all those
technologies they described on the
previous slide additional challenge is
really how do you explain them to the
users how do you make the user
understand and trust that those
technology will protect you know yoyoyo
genomic data so the challenge is not
only implementing the technology that
you're translating them into a psycho
transparency centered user experience
and this night just shows how our UI
looks like we're you know we show just
can communicate relatively directly this
you know this different individuals on
the platform who can remain anonymous
through the process but then you know
learn about who's talking with them we
know who the researcher is where he
works what he wants to use the data for
and then you know consent or not consent
for the day to be used for that
particular purpose
and as you mentioned correctly it's not
just about kind of one way just research
communicating with a it was individual
but after the data's being shared and
some study is done so that the
individuals actually receive some
feedback and can you know can you learn
about what was accomplished as their
help and we think that really engaging
that people this way is really important
to make them participate in research and
creating such a much more consumer or
patient setting platform it's a core
core approach to talk on Machinist yeah
and it even potentially goes into the
sphere of the more that you give your
open your valves and let the the data
flow for research the more that you can
potentially earn you can potentially
earn these credits on your platform you
teach us about the credit system yeah
it's actually quite interesting so this
option exists people can can if they
wish to we did a survey and actually
found out that many people are willing
to share the data for purely altruistic
reasons simply simply because they you
know they want to help researchers they
want to help find cures for diseases but
they want to stay in control of the data
they want they do not want to do CP in a
black hole and then don't know what
happens with it so they want full
control full transparency and then I
think there's you know a high level of
altruism and but yes this option exists
and I think some people will take this
option especially if they're in contact
with you know pharma companies and then
you know get get actually asked to be
paid for for giving access to the data
and for that we use you know our credit
system which which knows are based on oh
no on our cryptocurrency on on our blog
chain that can be no transfer between
between those researchers and the
individuals and the people who are on
those credits can then use them to
purchase various things on our platform
so for example even today if you already
call tune able to talk register we can
earn credits by just answering basic
service about your health and you can
and doing other things take for example
referring friends and
in fact today earn enough credits to get
free low pass whole genome sequencing
and over time there will be no more
things added that you can just buy with
your own credits which can be no
additional analytics or you know it kind
of even sinks s you know gift cards that
you can just you know take to Amazon
also whatever platform and then just buy
something for you know it's it's also
great to hear that there's a the
altruistic component is is coming up
that the people are like I don't need
the credits just you know just get the
scientific research done that has to be
done to help I think that's a very
important point you know when it would
you know when the kind of news stories
about you know a pharma company buying
out of genomic data there's kind of a
lot of backlash against this it's not
about people do not want to the data to
be used for research it's about know
that nobody asks them that it happens in
a in transparent way and they don't know
what's going on so that's a core issue
that needs to be addressed and as then I
think many people will be you know
gladly willing to share the data with
academic or industry researchers and the
inclusive stake holding to that that if
you if you can if you at least give the
people the option and say hey we're
already making twenty million dollars on
this data set being purchased for use
and does he would would you like a tiny
little cut because you you know of this
this amount of money you think well
people in as inclusive stakeholders yeah
and you know in our case it's you know
it won't be a time you look at guys we
we plan to give you know the users the
largest portion of you know whatever the
pharma companies paying to get access so
we will not be ourselves not you know
what's important is we are not in the
business of taking ownership of that
data we rather creating the
infrastructure to enable the researchers
to act as a network of people and then
they can ask those people whether they
can have access to their data so we will
charge pharma companies for giving them
access to that network but the pharma
companies wouldn't actually pay the
individual users for getting access to
the data
that's that's a big ethical stance that
you take and we we love that a lot
that's very very powerful if we can get
more people realizing that that these
ideas are coming through them to provide
the idea to the world and not for them
to earn material in the in the world
that that that I think will have a
better society from that Dennis I want
to know what's your you know the last
slide that we have is your team and you
know as you said earlier you and Kamal
as well as George are doing the the
co-founding of nebula how BIG's the team
now with with besides you three how
large is the team I think we have
fourteen people right now 14 yeah yeah
that's a big team already yeah yeah we
have been going quickly that's awesome
it's so good to hear and interest yeah
in just three years since conception -
now that's that's awesome I want to know
what do you how do you feel about the
these like ethical considerations that
are happening around you obviously very
much you know certainly privacy privacy
of course of course but at the same time
this is kind of like like synthetic
biology is another one of these
explosive fields like artificial
intelligence and neuroscience that is
that has
malevolent actors can gain lots of power
in the in the field so how do you how do
you feel about our ability to like fend
that often how can we do that best well
in terms of genomic data and I think
he'll stay in general there's a trend
right now to make the individuals you
know the owners of their own data and
the controller's of their own data and I
think that's a very good trend from
which not only the people themselves
will benefit but actually kind of
legitimate users who researchers in
academia industry who want to get access
to that data because for them it's also
much better to get access to an
individual and to be able to generate
data on demand rather than you know get
access to kind of a static data set was
kind of obtained in shady ways and a
user is much more valuable than just
such a static piece of data so it's a
trend I think that is good for everyone
it's good you know for privacy it's good
also for just facilitating research and
you know getting people more engaged and
it's only not good for people who or
entities who would like to I know take
take you know people's data and then
just monetize it for their own game in
you know opening very in transparent and
and not ethical ways and then doesn't it
doesn't part of like the whole movement
towards transparency the way sometimes I
envision a very you know spiritually
actualized and awakened world where
there aren't these malevolence 'iz and
then you can be radically transparent
like your data can live even without
potentially being anonymized is that
like an imagined that a future that you
can also think is is a is it possible
yeah I mean that's an open question
right so we have been talking about
possible risks like you know governments
using the data the risk of
discrimination like for example by
insurance companies the question is are
those risks real will they be you know
people affected in the future by that if
you don't implement you know different
privacy
for technical or not and people fill in
different ways about that there's for
example and as a project also started by
George it's called Personal Genome
Project and there it's all about
transparent it's also a genomics project
essentially and people who participate
in that they make the genome potentially
public on the Internet
yeah and for free too useful for
everyone without any restriction
interests and some some people are you
know fine designs they say is they are
not worried and maybe they're right
maybe the zoo we are we always to
meeting the risks we don't know but what
I was thinking is that we need to be
able to address the concerns otherwise
such as the progress will be hindered
because people are concerned that
judgeth as a matter of fact and to get
the more engaged in research to me to
Winston to convince them to share the
data we do need to address those
concerns otherwise research will just
them and progress was stagnated this is
a good to see the contrasting the
Personal Genome Project with iVillage it
yeah yeah we just which are both you
know good projects and just addressing
different audience great in that way the
scientific progress can just keep moving
exactly yes yes now what would be a
something that you know going into the
exponential age AI age that you would
recommend children to learn that you'd
recommend parents to teach kids parents
did learn themselves as well
that's a good question a to me
personally it has been very helpful to
have I would say even if not deep
knowledge but that is some understanding
of different fields so in my case it's
you know it's its genomics but on the
other hand you know it's computer
science over the past couple you said
becoming a cryptography increasingly and
that just enables you to just bring
things together in a way that most
people are not able to and by doing that
you can you can you know address
previously unsolved issues I just spoke
a few days with someone who who you know
was I believe interviewing some you know
really famous Nobel Prize winning
physicists and no really smart people
but then found that they just don't
understand you know basics of biology
like how some very basic things work and
that you know that person told me like I
was so surprised how can they possibly
not know things people who are in high
school those guys you know one you know
prices you know Nobel prizes in physics
and we can't know you do everything
you'd be the most hated person in the
world yeah well that's why we all have
to work together we have to respect each
other's individual intelligence and
bring it all together otherwise we're
doomed this is a very interesting point
about you know how a Nobel Prize
laureate may not know a high school
level in its different field this he you
know the multidisciplinary a perspective
having your lens that you see the world
with multiple disciplines is so crucial
I love how you said that and if we can
you know put that into need to play in
this exponential technology age I think
yeah yeah so to answer your question
more briefly and directly I think it's
very beneficial to have got to be
shallow knowledge but knowledge of you
know different areas and what can that
can the way you can focus apply
accomplish that is you know talking with
people from from different hills you
know as a physicist talk with biologists
and all these chemists yes
have no basic understanding what's going
on in those areas and some of you will
come across something which maybe you
can apply your knowledge in your in your
field that you an expert on to solve a
previously that's right problems that
those people in those other fields have
not been able to address before the
creative it helps so much with new
creative thinking and out-of-the-box
thinking people in one industry thinking
a certain way someone from a different
industry comes in and says hey have you
thought about it this way I can't boom
this is very beautiful stuff
Dennis some questions at the end of the
show our simulation questions let's ask
you first question are we alone in the
cosmos well I mean I read about you know
you know what's the name of this paradox
very very paradigm yeah paradox said you
know it's it's a statistically very
improbable that we are alone there are
probably some issues where you know
nobody ever contacted as the distance
maybe one maybe someones watching us and
we just don't know so so who knows it
would certainly be very exciting if you
found out one day yeah yeah yeah and how
about shows simulation so we'll ask you
are we in a simulation or that's even
that's in crazy
I would like to believe that we are not
III I mean if it is a simulation it's a
really good simulation I mean no one has
so far been you know be able to peek
take a look past past you know the
matrix on secret I'm not supposed to
talk about it I see them it's a pretty
good simulation it's a pretty good one
that's good
hopefully you know with science science
is such a cool tool that if we can probe
at the at the simulation and test that'd
be very interesting and the last
question we asked on the show is what is
the most beautiful thing in the world
well I don't know what it's the most
beautiful thing in the world but I can
tell you something that is very
beautiful from you know a scientist
perspective I think when you have you're
trying to solve a problem and you know
you have a hypothesis that you kind of
start start doing your research based on
and you do really a set of experiments
and validate that hypothesis step by
step and then in the end you discover
something novel and you know that's so
beautiful and you feel like you advanced
human knowledge by you know a little bit
and you know that makes one very happy
and you know think that's one beautiful
thing yes yes you're adding to the
foundation of collective learning and
with objectively and this is very
important with with reproducibility is
very important we had a one of our
previous guests was explaining it like
you have a you're on a big big beach
with sand and then what you do is you
add one cup of sand to the beach and I
was like oh my gosh that's a lot of work
for one cup of adding one cup of sand to
the beach yeah some some ideas are
breakthrough though like whoever Satoshi
Nakamoto and blockchain technology is
has been you know or maybe a truckload
of sand yeah each potentially yeah I
mean it's a trade-off right if you know
if you lived like few thousand years ago
the beach was pretty small back then it
was easy to add a lot to it today it's
much harder but the advantages that we
know just live in a in a better world
and you know benefit from all that
science that was at the beach yeah yeah
we keep that only only the highest
signal and least amount of noise on on
the on the foundation of knowledge
Dennis we love your work very much this
has been such an honor thank you for
coming on to our show and plus my
pleasure thank you we're very
appreciative keep up the great work
Thanks we're all counting on you I will
do my best it's great that your team's
so big now and that you're doing this
work everyone check out the links below
we would love for you to check out
nebula genomics also go and have more
conversations with people about what
it's like to have your personal
blueprint sequence so you can better
understand it and so that we can
contribute to this foundation of
collective knowledge talk to your family
your friends your commute
these get more people talking about this
about the biotech explosion huge shout
out to Ron Vargas our producer and
director much love thank you very much
and support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in
nebulous links are below
simulation our links are below support
us help us grow we would love to have
you more involved in our community and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much we will see you soon
peace thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]